- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here.
Welcome to our homeroom live stream.
Today, we have a disappointing guest.
It is me.
We'll be doing a ask me anything.
So feel free to start
putting your questions
in the message boards down below
or wherever they are on the
side on Facebook or on YouTube.
And we'll try to get to as many
of those questions as possible.
But before I begin, I'll give
my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist
through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position
to do so, please think
about making a donation
at khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout
out to several organizations
that have stepped
up when they found
out that we were having a
deficit even before COVID.
And then with COVID you
could imagine traffic
on Khan Academy has grown
dramatically, so special, thanks
to Bank of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, Novartis
and the many other folks who
have helped fund Khan Academy.
And, you know
I had given, we had a guest
several, two weeks ago
talking about how to be a happier person.
And one of the best ways to
be a happy person is to give
to others or to give to
missions that might help others.
So I believe all
of these organizations are now
we're going to be happier organizations
because of the work that
they know they're doing
for others and all of
y'all who are donating
hopefully feel the same.
Extra announcement reminder
about Homeroom with Sal, the podcast.
It's essentially what
you're getting right now
but in podcast version,
safe to drive while you are consuming it.
So with that, I'm eager to
answer any questions that
you have about anything.
And so let's see, it looks
like we already have a few
from our last time and we're
going to be adding more.
See Aaron Brandt says, "How
do your kids feel about math?"
I have a 11 year old, a nine
year old and a six year old.
My 11 year old is really into
math, very much into math.
So, you know,
if you give them a
interesting math problem
et cetera, et cetera, wants to tackle it.
Like really curious about it.
My nine and six year olds,
I think they are well
on their way, but they're still
in the kind of early phases
of their math progression.
But you could imagine this
is one area where it would be
I feel it would be a shame
if my children did not grow
up knowing the beauty of actually all
of learning, but especially
math and actually all
of the learning.
I want them to see wonder wherever they go
in the world and realize that
you know, all of this wonder,
we can start to understand it
through math, through science,
through the humanities.
So I'm working on it.
Let's see.
Next question from Christopher
McDade on Facebook.
Are there any specific new
subjects that you want to include
in Khan Academy?
Sorry, I just had a Quito
Popsicle, it's like a,
anyway that's a whole other conversation.
If y'all want me to talk more about that
but it's going down a little bit still.
Other subjects to add
on Khan Academy.
So, you know
we've talked about math and we
already have, you know, pre-K
with Khan Academy kids, K
first grade and second grade.
Now we're adding Khan Academy
mat on Khan Academy kids.
And that also has reading, writing
and social, emotional learning
at those same grade levels.
And in the math, we go all the way.
In fact, we've just launched all the way
through calculus statistics and
now multi-variable calculus.
We've always had videos, but
now we have exercises as well.
So I hope to keep adding
and building out our math.
Science, a lot of y'all
know, we already have a lot
of science content, but over
the course of the next year
expect to see even more science content.
By next back
to school, I'm hoping that
we have significant chunks
or if not, all of the major
things you need in middle school
and high school across
all of the sciences.
And then over time
you know, we already have
some English language arts
and history content, and
other humanities content.
I hope that we can add a lot
more over time, but you know
it goes back to my fundraising,
ask at the beginning
you know, we're, we're limited
by the resources we have
on not just the ability
to create the content
but also to make sure that our platform
our software, the
practice works really well
and is really a part of
the teacher tools work well
for the kind of content
we are trying to address.
So let's see the, let's see
there's a question here
incorporating arts for Khan Academy.
I don't think we're going to
be doing any like deep dive
in like teaching the arts
but we do have art history on Khan Academy
done by Beth and Steven,
who are close partners of Khan Academy
smart history, all that contents
available on Khan Academy.
So I encourage you to look into that.
So let's see from Facebook, Snahat Nath,
"Do you think standardized
testing will always be here
or do you think something
else will replace them?"
Well, you know, sometimes,
you know, standardized testing
a lot of people, you know, say, oh
well, that, that gives, you
know, it creates stress and all
of these types of things.
But I always remind folks
that, you know, the opposite
of standardized testing is
non-standardized testing
or not testing at all.
And if you're not measuring something
it's very hard to know
whether, you know it
or whether you're growing
or how well you know it.
And if it's done
in a non-standardized way,
well, that's not much better
because how do you understand
where you are compared
to where you need to be
in a standardized way?
So I would say that, you
know, generally speaking
in the world, you do need
standardized measurement
and standardized testing is that is a form
of standardized measurement
that we use in academics.
Now I do think
over time, standardized
testing is going to be expanded
or it's going to evolve.
I think the types
of standardized testing
that we're familiar
with, I think you'll always
have standardized tests.
That'll be, you know, how well
can you factor a polynomial?
How well, how strong is
your reading comprehension?
But I think then those
are going to be expanded
with new forms of standardized
assessment where, you know
maybe there's some type of how
well can you teach a subject?
How well can you
you know, compose a poem
or something like this
and that, you know,
having interesting ways
for maybe the community
to help evaluate you
in a standardized way.
So I don't think the notion
of standardized measurement
or standardized tests are going away
nor should they go away.
But I think over time they will
evolve and we'll have a kind
of a broader aperture
of what and how they can measure things.
So let's see,
from Facebook Rom says,
"Why do you use your name?
Why don't you use your name
as Salmaan instead of Sal?"
So Salmaan is my, my full first name.
My full name is Salmaan Khan.
So the reason why I go
by Sal, you know, it's really
what my mother has called me
from the beginning.
So this, you know
a lot of times folks, especially
folks who have a name that is not
familiar to folks where they live
they'll sometimes shorten their names.
And you know
definitely a lot of folks
in my family have done that.
My mother's name is Masuda.
And for convenience purposes,
I was probably around 12
or 13 years when she decided to tell
people who are not familiar
with the name of Sue though,
that her name was Sue.
You know, I have an Uncle Azad.
He goes by Zach.
I have an Uncle Mucbul.
He goes by Mac.
I have an Uncle Khalid who actually goes
by Jason, which is completely unrelated.
He was a, he worked
on a ship for a while and he
was always fascinated by Jason
the famous sailor.
I have an Uncle Arshot who goes
by Daniel, once again,
not an obvious shortening of the name.
He, he liked that song, you know.
♪ Daniel is traveling tonight on a plane ♪
Anyway, long story short,
that's not the cause
of my name going from Salmaan to to Sal.
It really is that my mom,
I think just found it
convenient to call me Sal
when I was growing up.
And then it did just happen
to kind of stick in my head
but I respond to either Sal or Salmaan,
whatever works for folks.
Let's see other questions here
from, see, I answered that one.
So from YouTube
Joshua Katavil said,
"How do you think
artificial intelligence will
either help or damage the
current world of technology?"
That's a big question.
I don't claim to be the
world's leading expert
on artificial intelligence.
But I do like to traffic
in futurist ideas.
I, first of all
I think the genie's out of the box.
Artificial intelligence is
going to be increasingly used.
I think one of the hard things
about artificial
intelligence is it can create
you know, positive optimizations
for a lot of things
but sometimes you don't know
why it's choosing one thing
or another.
And so I think artificial
intelligence can have many
many very, very positive uses.
You know, a lot of mundane human tasks
will not have to be done
in a mundane way by human beings.
You'll have, I could imagine artificial
intelligence is that can
help improve your motivation,
that can help you learn.
Hopefully one day Khan Academy
can incorporate things like that
that can improve your
relationship with someone else.
You know, it asks the right questions so
that it builds bonds between
you and another human being.
You know, yesterday we talked a lot
with the former surgeon general
about kind of a loneliness epidemic.
And, you know, it seems
a little dystopian if
your loneliness is partly addressed
with an artificial intelligence
but there is, you know,
maybe something powerful
about, you know, sometimes
being able to confide
in something that, you
know, isn't going to,
where your secrets are safe.
So I dunno, there, there could
be some positive use cases
but then there could be a lot of
weird use cases too.
I mean, that last one I
gave where, where people's
best friends ended up becoming
not a real human being
or artificial intelligence is
you know, there's several examples
of them developing their own
biases based on the data that
I mean, in fact, a lot of machine learning
is all about kind of
forming a bias, but some
of those biases can be very,
very unhealthy and you don't
and it might be expressing
in very subtle ways.
So, yeah, I think it's going to be very
it's going to be a brave new world.
The next 10 or 20 years is,
you know, we really grapple
with how artificial intelligence is used
or not, but it's gonna,
it's gonna be interesting.
So from Facebook, my name is Patrice
and I will be 60 years old next year.
"Would it be possible
for me to study mathematics
abinitio using Khan Academy
and work my way to a first
degree, BA or BS in mathematics?
Can Khan Academy give
me a good foundation."
So, Patrice, first of
all, I love that goal.
I think you're fully capable of doing it.
My advice to you would be start
on Khan Academy at the basics, at like
you know, you could probably
you could probably,
whatever level you think is
is kind of a little bit
easier than where you are.
And it could be as early
as if you haven't even done
you know, basic arithmetic
for many, many years.
Just go back to the beginning,
go to math on Khan Academy
or maybe second or third
grade math on Khan Academy
start from the beginning
and master everything.
I think if you put, you know, you'll get
you'll get through those
first two things very quickly,
those first many grade levels.
I think if you're like a lot
of adults probably around
you know, some of the
more advanced arithmetic
with decimals and maybe some
exponents and negative numbers
that's when you're going to start
needing some significant
refreshers, that's going to be
in fifth, sixth, seventh
grade math, and then a lot
of adults I think need, need
help refreshing in the algebra.
But if you did that, I would
say for 30 to 40 minutes a day
say five days a week, I
think you're going to, first
of all, be at your learning
edge in about a week or two.
So you'll probably be
at some of that, that early algebra stuff.
And then you keep going master algebra
master geometry, algebra two,
master trigonometry, pre-calculus,
calculus, statistics.
And if you want to be a math major
I would say, then go on into
multi variable calculus.
Now you can do all of
that on Khan Academy.
Now that's going to take you some time
depending on where you are.
I think that might take
at least probably a year
or so, depending on where
you are on your journey
but we've had, I've gotten
letters from people in your boat
who've done it in about that timeframe.
Maybe it might take a little bit longer.
And if you did that, you would
have an excellent foundation
for becoming a math major in college.
On top of that
we have videos on differential
equations and linear algebra.
We don't have exercises on those yet
but I encourage you to
watch those pause the video
try to work through it yourself
before I worked through it.
And so, because
if you have a good foundation
in algebra and calculus in a
and especially more advanced
calculus and linear algebra
I don't think the math
degree will be a problem, but
you know, it's, it'll, it will
be a journey I would predict
if you do this diligently,
you'll be ready to enroll
at a local university
in about a year or two.
And then you, you you'd be off
to the races on your degree.
So late.
Let's see.
Next question.
From YouTube Michael Walker asked,
"How do you stay motivated Sal Khan?"
I mean, sometimes it's hard to see
the big picture when you
were an undergraduate
and graduate student
what did you do to keep on track?
You know the thing that I remind myself
is that life is short.
And I, you know, I, maybe I
was an old soul even when I was
in high school or when I was
in college, but I always
felt that life is short.
And the last thing that I
wanted to do is to kind of
you know, make, not make good use
of whatever precious moments
I had on this planet.
And so for me, you know, I like everyone
I have those days where things are not
going my way and I'm not,
you know, let's call it,
I don't have the best
self-esteem sometimes.
But I just remind myself that, that
you know, as much as I can,
I try to coach myself to say
well, you know, that's
not going to help me.
So let me do some small steps
that might get me out of my funk.
And I've talked about this before
you know, I've made my bed religiously now
for about 20 something years
because that's one small step.
You're like, hey, at least I made my bed.
And then, you know, every
morning I try to do some pushups.
I try to do some, pull-ups.
A new thing I've started over
the last two, three years
is I take cold showers.
All of these things
have a way, I meditate
every day, 30 minutes
and all of these things, they
do, they do two things for me.
They give me wins no matter
what the day is going like,
no matter what headwinds I'm facing
or how I'm feeling about myself
or the world, I'm like, I
made my bed, I got in there.
I took that cold shower
which is like a reboot of your brain.
I meditated which is also like
another type of reboot of your brain.
It kind of just opens it up.
You, you start to really
still your mind, all those
whatever negative thoughts
they become a lot less
than, than they were.
And you start, you know
some positive thoughts start
to slowly, slowly come out.
At least I find that when I meditate
and then you do some exercise
gets your blood flowing
and it makes you feel accomplished.
And then, you know
if you can do that, if you do
that sort of thing, at least
for me, that set of things,
you know, if I can do that
in the first hour or two of my day
that I'm like, this is
going to be a good day.
And you know, sometimes
it is sometimes it isn't.
But I gotta say, especially the meditation
even when something happens at work and it
you know, it's disappointing
or something in the family
and I'm like, ah, this
is going to be so hard.
The meditation helps you
from getting overly attached
to whatever that scenario
is, or even overly attached
to your own ego or, or your own fears.
And when you're not overly attached
to those things, then
they don't feel as heavy.
At least that's what I feel for myself.
So, you know, if I had to pick
out of all of those habits
I would, I would probably
pick making the bed
and meditating if I had
to do only two things
and meditating start five minutes.
And literally there's
nothing mysterious about it.
You just sit, you know, I try
to sit upright in a chair,
hands on my lap and, you
know, kind of close my eyes
Take some deep breaths in and out.
In fact, do that right now.
Just take some deep breaths in and out.
And then I just start, you
know, focusing on my breaths
and I try to steal my
mind as much as possible.
Actually I was, I was
going there just now.
So, but anyway, I, that's what I do.
Maybe one day we'll do a meditation over
this live stream, but I encourage
you to, you know, you see
even those deep breaths, you
know, taking the deepest breath
of your, of your week or your month
in (inhaling) and out (exhaling).
You'd be surprised what that does for you.
And there's some good biology behind it.
It activates your parasympathetic system
which is the opposite of
your sympathetic system
which is your fight or flight response.
So it, it forces your body to relax.
And then you still, your
mind then everything
all of a sudden feels a lot less heavy.
Let's see YouTube, Jason Suhei says,
"Sal, I have learned many
subjects in my young life
and have trouble retaining
that knowledge over time.
How do you retain the vast amount
of information that you've
procured over the years?"
So I would say there's two
or three ways to really retain knowledge.
One is is while you're learning
try to make as many connections
as you can.
Say okay, yeah, that's what I do
for the test, but let me
draw some more connections.
Let me derive that formula.
Okay, this formula in
physics class says this
but I think I saw something very similar
in my calculus class.
Or, hey, they're talking about
entropy and computer science
and they're also talking
about entropy in a chemistry.
How are these things related?
And the more that you ponder these things
the more that those
connections will be there.
The second thing I'd recommend
is just applying them
and you know, the, the
best way to apply a lot
of these skills is actually
to teach it to other people.
So if you teach
if you make a habit of,
after you take a course
the students who take it the next year
you want to teach that course, trust me
not only you're going to
learn it much, much deeper
but you're going to
retain that information
much much better.
Some of you all know I have the
side project schoolhouse.world,
separate effort from Khan Academy,
but it is a place where you can do that.
Where if you need tutoring,
you can get free tutoring.
But if you want to go deeper
and your subject matter, you can go tutor.
And actually we had an announcement with
University of Chicago recently
that they are going to be looking
at students who are really good tutors
of a subject because they see
if you can tutor the subject
not only do you know the subject
but that means you have
great communication
you have empathy.
And frankly, you're probably
going to retain that subject.
And I think you're going to see a more
and more of that in the future.
So I highly recommend you to start
tutoring the subject
yourself and using it.
And then the third thing is
you know, if you can, if you can keep
revisiting the subject either
because you're tutoring it or because
you know, you just continue to stay
curious that will also reinforce it,
so the idea of staying in your head.
So let's see.
From YouTube Fatay Sidesal says.
"Your English is very fluent.
What tips do you recommend
to improve my English?"
Well I can't take too much credit
for my English being fluent
because I was born in, in the U.S.
in Metairie, Louisiana.
And actually many people are surprised
that I have what they perceive
as a very neutral American accent
despite the fact that I grew
up in Southeast Louisiana,
but people don't realize
that Metairie, Louisiana has
kind of a neutralish accent.
Although there is a little bit of a
it's called a YAT accent
that you kind of hear there.
You'll hear my y'all every now
and then, but that's why
I have very fluid English.
So I can't take much credit for that.
Other languages that I
kind of know, my Bengali
and my Hindi/Urdu is not very fluent.
It is (speaking foreign language) accent.
That's my Hindi/Urdu and my Bengali.
(speaking foreign language)
That was my Bengali.
So anyway, I just telling you know
that it's always a journey
when you're not looking
at your native language.
Actually, those are my languages
where my family grew up,
but those aren't the ones that I grew up.
But my advice for you, if you know
my theory, and I'm not
a linguistics expert
is try to find people you
can have conversations with.
And the beauty
of the internet now is you don't have to
necessarily travel to meet
people who are fluent,
who are native speakers in
whatever language you want.
So I would recommend if
you want to become fluent
in English, I've got to believe,
in fact I'm 100% sure there's
places on the internet where
you can practice your English
with native English speakers.
And I think if you do a lot
of that, not only will
your English improve
but you'll probably meet
some interesting folks
and they'll have a chance to meet you.
So let's see
from YouTube, Andrew Briggs says,
"Do you have anything about
religion on Khan Academy?"
We actually have a good bit about religion
on Khan Academy from a
historical cultural lens.
Especially if you look at
our world history content,
we have a lot
on kind of the Eastern traditions
on Hinduism on Buddhism.
We have a lot on what I would say,
you know, the more, I guess
you say Western religions,
I guess mid Eastern religions is the rest.
You know, so we have a lot
we have a reasonable bit on
the core of Judaism, you know
at least understanding the
narrative of the old Testament.
We have a good bit
about the, at least the
gospels, the kind of the life
of Jesus and how Christianity
evolved from the time of Jesus
under the Roman empire, all
the way through Constantine
when the Roman empire, you
know, they transitioned
from persecuting
Christians to becoming the
you know, the kind of
the seat of Christianity.
And we talk about, we have a
good about four or five videos
on Islam where you can understand
you know, the historical
underpinnings of it, how it started
and how it grew historically.
So that's what we have right now.
I hope one day
you know, we get a chance
to go deeper on all
of these, because regardless
of whether you follow any
of these religions or you
don't, whether you are religious
whether you're atheist,
whatever your belief system is
it's really valuable to
understand these religions
which are, you know
formed the base of so much of
our thought and our culture.
So I highly recommend you're
taking a look at those things
on Khan Academy, if you're
not familiar with any of them.
So let's see other questions.
Let's see, I'm scrolling.
There's a question here from YouTube.
Mr. Specter asks, "Is your job stressful?
How do you make all
these educational videos?
How do you manage to make this
nonprofit organization bloom?"
So it's a good question, Mr. Specter.
I'll tell you, there are
times that it is stressful.
I'll tell you the video
making is not usually
my source of stress.
Sometimes it's a little
frustrating cause you know
I keep bumbling over myself
or I really want to make sure
I understand something really
really well so I can get a
little bit compulsive about that.
But for the most part, I find the
video creation side to be almost
the relaxing side of my job.
It allows me to kind of, that's
where I get into my flow,
when I get into my Zen.
I think the stuff that gets stressful
and you know, is there
there's a lot of folks who
are dependent on Khan Academy.
There's, you know, that
we have over 200 employees
there's thousands of
volunteers around the world.
We have hundreds of thousands of donors.
We have tens of millions, if not hundreds
of millions of users.
And so, yeah, when, when
people are dependent on it
you don't want to disappoint
folks and you can imagine
you know, raising money, if
I don't raise enough money
then we're not going to have
the resources to serve tens
of millions of folks, or
we're not able to hire folks.
Or, you know, even in the past
we've had to downsize some
at Khan Academy, which is
an incredibly painful thing.
So those types of things
develop a lot of stress.
I would say there's there's
times also, when, you know
you have passionate people who are
trying to do the right thing.
The root of passion is worth suffering.
When you really care
about something, you know
we can have heated debates
within Khan Academy
of, you know, with the
scarce resources we have
what is the best way to deploy that?
Or what is the best
way to execute on that?
And so, you know, I often do think
about, you know, am I
supporting our team properly?
Are we aligned?
Are we working
on the right things.
You know, are the funders satisfied?
You know, am I communicating
with them enough?
So yeah, these, these can
sometimes make you wake
up in the middle of the night
but that's why I meditate
and take cold showers
and do my push-ups and
pull-ups, and make my bed.
And I make videos too that all,
and I don't want to make it
sound like my whole, you know
my job is like, you know,
some super stressful thing.
It comes and goes, you know.
There's moments of real joy.
In fact it's mostly that,
but yeah, there are definitely moments
of stress and that how I deal with it.
I will say one thing, you know, I remember
when I used to read, I
don't, I would read, like
I would watch like movies and there'd be
like someone who runs a company
and they'd always be like
Oh, it's so lonely at the top.
And I'd be like, yeah,
it seems like it would
be so awesome to be the boss.
'Cause then you get to, you
know, whatever, you're the boss.
How awesome is. I have to
say and not to feel sorry.
I mean, cause I feel very privileged
and lucky to have the role that
I have, but yeah, sometimes
sometimes the stress is, 'cause you know
you really can't tell other
folks everything that's going on
in your head.
And so you have to figure out ways to
resolve your own head sometimes.
But yeah, those are all the stresses.
See other questions here.
So someone's, so I use, she's asking
for the photo explanation
of the photoelectric effect.
I'm tempted, but we have
videos on that on Khan Academy.
So I encourage you to go there
and if that's not satisfying, let us know.
And we'll, I'll make another video
to answer any other
questions you might have.
Let's see from Facebook,
Victoria Angela Umedo says,
"I'm working on getting a GED,
but I get overwhelmed,
worried and stressed.
Any advice?
Thank you."
Well, my advice is, you know
if anyone's getting overwhelmed
or stressed about anything
one, you can't underestimate the power
or you can't overestimate the power
of meditation even five, 10 minutes a day.
Once again, this is nothing mystical.
It's just you being able
to observe your thoughts
recognize that you are not your thoughts.
You are not those negative
feelings that you are.
You know, those feelings
are real they're happening
inside your brain, but you
are something more than that.
And that, you know
when you start to observe,
your mind starts to still
and you do literally
feel kind of a space form
and you can see, okay, there's
this thought that saying
oh, I'm not going to be
able to achieve my goal
or what are people gonna
think of me and all of that.
But you're like, well, that's
just a thought that's not me.
And then slowly that kind of can die down.
And that I find once I get
to that point, I'm just like,
you know what, regardless
of the outcome, let me just
do what's the right next step.
And if I just do the right
next step, I'll make progress.
Hopefully, and the chips
fall where they do, you know
yesterday, our guests
of Vavek, he talked about the
former surgeon general talked
about are reacting with hope.
Are we acting with love or
are we acting with fear?
And I think, you know, this feelings
of procrastination feeling overwhelmed,
these are feelings of fear.
You're like, Oh, well, what if I do this
and it doesn't work out.
And you know, people
are going to think this
about me and that's going to happen.
I'm not going to get that opportunity.
Instead, I would say, try to act
out of love or hope or however
you want to describe it.
We say, well, you know what?
I'm just going to do the right thing
at any step of the way,
put one foot in front
of the other, try to make
progress, be a little bit further
along today than I was yesterday,
a little bit further along
in the next hour than I
was in the previous hour.
And that you're going to notice
that you're making progress.
I mean, it's like climbing a big mountain.
You just put one foot in front
of the other and you know,
before you know it, you look back
and you've, you've actually
made a lot of progress.
So that'd be my, my meta advice.
I would say, just make a
habit of doing the practice.
When you get things wrong
don't beat up yourself, remind yourself.
That's actually moments
of growth, reflect on why you
got it wrong and keep going.
You know, I, I'm a amateur
guitarist and you know
there are these guitar chords that
you know, I've never been a fan
of, but lately I've been
like, you know what?
I needed to just keep
practicing them everyday.
And it is amazing that your
your brain slowly, just these
things that felt impossible
for you after a week or two
all of a sudden feel very
natural and very automatic.
So I would just say, keep
at it, keep a habit of it.
And you know, and always keep perspective.
Let's see, Oh, we're all out of time.
This goes, this goes by
very, very, very fast.
So I will leave y'all there.
I'll give one final announcement.
Next week I'm sure many people
if you're 18 or over, have
already voted through your mail
in ballots, but remember on
Tuesday it's election day.
So definitely vote.
We're only going to have
one live stream next week
on Wednesday, we're going to have former
Secretary of Education,
Margaret Spellings.
And I think there's going to
be a very similar conversation
to what we had a conversation
with RD Dunkin last week
but really just about,
you know, what's going
on in education and how we
can best navigate the kind
of the education crisis
due to COVID together.
So look forward to seeing all
of y'all next Wednesday at
12 Pacific, three Eastern.
See you then.
(logo chiming)